hey this is Pete peppers and here to
talk about the new game mode or level
type and candy crush soda saga
it's called Jam and it's pretty
interesting I was thinking about it I
don't know of any other games that have
a feature like this I don't play them
all so there might be one but it's
pretty interesting and it changes up the
strategy a lot instead of removing
something from the board you're trying
to cover the board in this case it's Jam
and by making matches over top of a
square that has Jam it'll spread out to
wherever that match goes so you know you
can see here that we have this blue
match that we can make if we move the
blue piece here it'll it'll cover these
two squares plus anything else that gets
matched in the process or if we move it
to the left then no Jam will spread so
we want to go this way and it just
spreads out and what's written what's
interesting is the specials when they're
on here and you fire them off from the
jam it'll spread the jam throughout that
that same row so you can see that you
can on this level this is an easy one
but um you can spread it pretty quickly
so we have a color bomb here I'm going
to go ahead and so this fish okay it's
on it's on the jam I'm going to match it
on the jam and you see that gets covered
and spreads it out to that that way and
then same with the color bomb if we I'm
going to go ahead and make this wrapped
first but when I hit this orange one
it'll spread jam to these other ones
ones that aren't on the block
so that changes things up pretty much
pretty considerably it's pretty cool
she's the same with this if I match the
fish with the the raft you know it
spread it into those ones and you know
this is an easy level but it gets a
little tricky when you only have one or
a couple ones that are need to be
covered how fish is good in this
situation because if we can't make a
match right over top of that we can set
a fish like this and it will go to the
uncovered square and finish off the
level for you
so like I said this is an easy one it's
a nice little rectangle there's no
blockers there's no spaces there's no
odd shaped pieces of the board sticking
off or anything that are hard to get to
so that's the basic functionality of how
it works
it gets interesting like on this one for
example here we have the board it's
split in two and we have JM up here but
we can't get to it
immediately we have to figure out a way
to get a special to slide up there so
color ball match there so you know like
if I I would want to move the color bomb
up there but since I have a color
bombing stripe together these will turn
into stripes and one of them will fire
off in this direction and spread the jam
into the new area where it's not and
then it's a lot easier to finish it off
so I I had some people comment that they
thought this before that I think it's
really interesting and I think it opens
up a whole new it opens up a whole new
layer to the game as far as the strategy
is concerned in the latest episode every
level was a jam level and so there was
lots of different varieties and I can I
think I go get pretty interesting as
they progress the main thing it with it
is you know to try to use your specials
in a way that they'll spread the jam out
over you know a significant part of the
board so that you can any matches that
you make and Cascades and things will
also spread the jam so I hope this
clears up how it works if you have any
questions you can leave a comment below
and I'm going to be writing a detailed
guide to go along with us to explain
some of the some of the tips that go
along with it if you
if you found this video helpful please
like it make sure you subscribe to our
channel so you get knew how to play
videos and all the latest levels as soon
as they come out subscribe to us on
YouTube and I'll be making more videos
there's new things I ran it into the
game so check back regularly and thanks
for watching we'll have a new video soon